This video is brought to you by Squarespace,
from websites and online stores to marketing tools and analytics.
Squarespace is the all in one platform to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business.
Check out Squarespace through the link in the description below more about them
in a bit.
Sometimes history throws us a figure. So dynamic,
it seems like they've witnessed every important events of their era.
In the case of the Marquis de Lafayette, he didn't just witness these events.
He often caused them born in the latter half of the 18th century.
Lafayette's life reads like a spec scripts for an Epic Oscar winner.
As a teenager, he fought in the American revolutionary war as a young man.
He spearheaded the first phase of the French revolution before fleeing a death
sentence at the guillotine. He was friends with George Washington, Louis,
the 16th,
Thomas Jefferson and Simon Boulevard then was instrumental in both the downfall
of Napoleon.
And as the revolution that overthrew Francis lost Borbon King and Schultz
laughing. Yes, it was a dude who packs a lot into his seven decades,
but while he remains famous for his role in the revolutionary war,
how much do we really know about the rest of his life,
about the man who was at the forefront of North one, but two French revolutions.
Join us today. As we peak inside the life of the market, you laugh.
I ask the man who changed the fate of both America and Europe.
[Inaudible].
When the market user Lafayette was born on September the sixth, 1757 in France.
It was into an old noble family of soldiers. In fact,
the Marquis de Lafayette is an aristocratic title,
but since his real name was Marie Joseph, Paul evade, Roche, Gilbert emoji,
Marquis de Lafayette.
We're just going to go with Lafayette for the rest of this video because it's
easier. But while young Lafayette was both pampered and connected,
he learns to ride horses in the company of three future Kings life.
Wasn't exactly easy. When he was barely two,
his father was killed fighting in the seven years war.
By the time he turned 13 and 1770,
it also lost his mother and his grandfather still the gigantic fortune.
He inherited it must have softened the blow come 1774 laugh.
I was married and the courtier routes,
the Versailles of newly crowned King Louis, the 16th.
But Lafayette came from fighting stock. The pompous luxury of a side bought him.
He wanted to win glory as a soldier to go and fight in some great war somewhere.
Luckily for him, one of the greatest Wars in history,
it was about to blow up on April the 19th, 1775,
the growing animosity between Britain and its American colonies finally exploded
when a bunch of soldiers and local militiamen clashed at the towns of Lexington
and Concord. It was the opening salvo of the revolutionary war.
Often referred to as the shot heard around the world over in France,
the Marquis de Lafayette certainly heard it by the summer of 1777,
19 year old laugh. I added,
it becomes so obsessed with the war raging in America,
that he decided to go and join in that July.
He arrived in Philadelphia where he presented himself to the continental
Congress. The Congress took one,
look at this scrawny teenager with no battle experience and told him to perform
an act of intercourse upon his own buttocks.
At least they did until the market declared that he was willing to fight for
free at which points the calculation changed. And the summer of 1777,
the war was not going well for the Americans. Smallpox was devastating.
Their ranks that only one symbolic victories, as opposed to useful ones.
And the British were on the verge of capturing Philadelphia right now,
Congress would take any free help they could get,
which was out George Washington found himself on July the 31st face-to-face with
a rich French teenager who had somehow been given the rank of major general
Washington had been settled before with useless European Royals.
He came over to find because they were rich and looking for adventure.
Invariably, they turned out to be useless, even as Canon Nevada.
There was no reason to assume that this new one would be any difference,
but Washington's snap judgment.
What turned out to be wrong over the month of August 17, 77,
Lafayette arose from being someone Washington couldn't stand the sight of to his
personal favorite.
They tell us that Lafayette was brave and battle and a natural leader of men at
blank. Blankly helps even more.
That both Washington and Lafayette were looking for someone to fill an emotional
hole in their lives. As many have noted,
Lafayette wound up becoming the childless Washington's surrogate son at the same
time,
Washington seems to have filled the father shaped void and Lafayette's life.
The two became incredibly close in a matter of weeks where Lafayette was wounded
in the backs of the Brandywine that autumn Washington had his personal
physician. It tends to the lab.
It was the start of a long relationship that would hugely influenced both men.
It would also hugely influence the course of American history.
[Inaudible].
Under Washington's tutelage, the Maki soon blooms into a great general.
He pulls off an impossible retreat from barren Hill and was instrumental in
harrying Benedict Donald's forces in 1781 more importantly, though,
he seemed became the fledgling nation's best ambassador in 1779, Lafite attra,
tons of froms to drum up support for the American revolutionaries.
Although Louis the 16th didn't need much convincing that screwing with Brisbane
was trebian. It's still impressive.
How much age the Maki returned with in April 17, 80 laugh.
I answered triumphantly reported to Washington,
that 6,000 infantry and six ships while on their way from France.
That is the most impressive moment of all would come in 1781 that summer in the
run-up to Yorktown Washington, watered both Lafayette and mad.
Anthony wanes head South into Virginia,
both their troops mutinied at the news of yet more fighting.
But while Matt Anthony lived up to his reputation by executing the ringleaders
and displaying their bodies, Lafayette took a different approach.
He told his men, they were free to go.
He leveled with the soldiers saying they were heading into danger,
that many of them would make it, that the British might annihilate them all,
but he also reminded them what they were fighting for.
Why that signed up to be in the first place,
what this new nation could represent in the wake of Lafayette speech,
nearly all of the dessert is returned. Now,
if I rewarded them by spending his own money on new boots and blankets,
and then as one they marched down toward Yorktown and did the history,
it was Paul and he was responsible for trapping law.
Charles called Wallace at Yorktown in late July,
once Cornwallis surrendered on October the 19th,
it was effectively the end of the revolutionary war in the aftermath of the
British, having their offices handed to them.
Lafayette was hailed as the hero of two Wells.
Many of the States made him an honorary citizen returning to France.
He was promoted to Michelle to come Paul Brigadier general.
It was a proud time in the Maki's life.
Not yet 25 had helped engineer the success of the American revolution at that
time, the most significant revolt in living memory literal,
could he have known that this was just a warmup for the main act
In the latter half of the 1780s, France made a grizzly discovery. It was broke.
The Royal treasury was empty.
Credit lines were maxed out in the face of a Countrywide financial collapse.
Louie, the 16th made a fateful decision. The summons, the estates general,
the estates general was a meeting of Frances three estates.
The aristocracy to which laugh.
I belonged the church and the commoners generally French Kings avoided calling
the estates general. The last meeting had been in 16, 14, 174 years previously.
But if Louie wanted to head off the Bruin crisis,
he had no choice on may the fourth, 1789,
1,200 representatives of the three estates convened in Paris.
Along that number was laughed at. It likes it as a deputy of the nobility,
but while I laugh, I was lumped in with all the other French fancy pantsy.
Wasn't just another posh twit had spent years immersed in the ideals of American
independence.
And now he was going to bring them to frumps whether his countrymen liked it or
not.
The estates general officially opens on may the fifth and quickly devolved from
a meeting about state finances to a massive pylon in which everyone
took turns about the ALCL regime. The Coleman is, Oh,
we're fed up with living in convoluted backwards,
froms filled with pointless privileges and regressive taxation,
but they were also fed up with being out-voted and pushed around by the other
two estates. So on June the 17th,
the third estates deputies declared themselves.
They sovereign national assembly.
The whole thing was organized with the help of laugh.
I asked one of the few Nobles who joined the assembly.
The King tried to council by having the meeting hall logs,
but the assembly repaired to a tennis court where everyone took an oath not to
disband until that forced a liberal constitution on France.
And they had just the guy to write it with help from his buddy,
Thomas Jefferson,
Lafayette drafted the declaration of rights of men and of the citizen.
One of the most important documents ever written in its Lafayette Sandtown his
conception of universal rights with a strong emphasis on personal Liberty.
Although the assembly would redraft his work before adopting it.
Lafayette's ideas still heavily influenced the final version,
but the Markey's effects on the French revolution.
Weren't going to stop with one document.
Three days after laughing had presented the assembly with his draft,
a prissy and mob storms, the best deal and the Paris hotel Deville,
a fancy name for city hall.
The morning after representatives of Paris is 60 districts convened on the hotel
and declared the creation of their own national assembly.
The Paris commune as part of this shake of it.
Citywide national guard was formed to replace the King's men and who could be a
more natural fit as commander of the guards.
Then the hero of two worlds on July, the 17th,
they reluctance Louie came down from Versailles to meet the man.
Now heading the army that effectively controlled Paris.
He was taken inside the hotel developer, someone pins,
a revolutionary red and blue co-located on his chest.
Lafayette saw the King wearing the Caucasians, had a flash of inspiration,
taking some whites class whites, being the color of the bulb and monarchy.
He added a strip to the Kings Caucasians, then Lafayette and blue.
The sixteens both went out onto the balcony where they gathered prisons shouted
long, left the King. It was the birth of the Tricolore,
the revolutionary symbol that is still the flag of France.
It was also the marquee. He hoped the birth of a liberal Republic.
One in which the King was a figurehead and to the actual governing was done by
middle-class business types. But the market would be proven wrong on this one,
far from wanting the King as a figurehead, the people of Paris.
We're soon going to realize that they preferred their Kings without heads at
all. And just before the French inevitably start lopping off people's heads.
We do want to take a moment to tell you about today's wonderful sponsor,
Squarespace with Squarespace. There's two things to keep in mind. One,
maybe you've got some idea for a website or a business or a podcast or something
knocking around in your mind. Well, two,
the only way to figure out whether that's worth doing is to get it out there
into the world.
And that could be daunting because it's scary to go and pursue new things,
but not knowing how to set up a website is not an excuse.
There are no excuses available with Squarespace.
Squarespace allows you to create a powerful website for whatever you're up to.
Do you want to sell something online? Yes. Easily set up store with Squarespace.
You want to do a podcast? Absolutely. They handle that too.
It all starts on Squarespace with a stunning template that you can customize to
your heart's content. Or you could start from scratch,
or you can move over from an existing domain, but just take my advice,
use a template. They look great. It's easy, no excuses.
And once you've gone through the easy customization process, no updates,
no tech, the has to deal with none of that nonsense and Squarespace,
all sounds all the website stuff. I said, they do podcasts,
also mailing as social integrations, all of that stuff,
and much more 24 seven customer support.
If you got stocks that had to squarespace.com for a free trial,
and when you're ready to launch go to squarespace.com/biographics to save 10%
off your first purchase of a website or a domain let's get back to
On Lafayette. Plant started coming off that same autumn on October the fifth,
uh, right over bread prices in Paris, turned into an army of heavily armed,
very unhappy women. The next day,
they marched on the size of 19 kilometers distance. When Lafayette has got word,
he first tried to stop them only to realize his guardsmen would mutiny if he did
so. So the Marquis changed tack and rode down to the head of the angry women
nominally there to protect them.
But to actually wondering what the hell he was going to do when the mob arrived,
a Lafayette zipped inside the palace to try and convince Louis to announce the
support for the assemblies liberal reforms. While he was talking,
the crowds invaded the palace,
where they killed two gods and stuck their heads on Pikes, the situation,
getting desperate. Lafayette forced the King onto a balcony to say his peace.
It was a tense moment.
The crowd could have easily broken in and lynched doctress Louie, but laugh.
I had to, luckily though, the plan worked, the crowns began hollering long,
live the King, do a score to live in his family back to Paris. We say offered,
but it was more like they ordered him on the strict understanding that saying no
would result in his head being stuck on a pike too.
And so the Royal family escorted back to the Capitol and effectively imprisoned
in the 2d a palace, but Lafayette had bought them time.
Not only that had bought himself influence with the mob from now on,
he was going to be at the very forefront of the French revolution for the next
year and a half. That's exactly where laugh.
I had stood as the assembly abolished feudalism and stripped powers from the
aristocracy. He was the most visible symbol of the changes under his watch,
the Wars Rosie gains new rights.
It was the mannered liberal revolution of Lafayette streams. Sadly,
it was already slipping out of his grasp.
The Monkees fall from grace came on July the 17th, 1791. On that day,
the Paris national guard opened the fire and a group of protestors demanding the
King's resignation. 50 people were injured or killed as commander of the guard.
Lafayette's popularity plummeted. He resigned his post,
had himself transferred into the army with Lafayette sidelines.
The radical elements began gaining power by April, 1792, the craziest war.
So in a sense that France declared war on Austria,
beginning a series of conflicts that would rack Europe for a quarter of a
century,
sends a lead one of the three main armies Lafayette Fritz ends from the front to
Paris twice to denounce the radicals and plead for common sense.
But no one was listening on August the 10th, 1792,
a working class revolt in Paris over through the monarchy, right?
Brought the hyper radical faction, headed by Robespierre to power.
Seeing which way the winds were blowing.
Lafayette abandoned his post and cross the lines into enemy territory.
And it was just in time to before news even arrived as desertion,
the assembly declared Lafayette to tracer effectively an invitation to come and
dance with Madame guillotine. But although Lafayette escaped with his head,
his nightmare wasn't over arrested by the Austrians, the marquee,
it spent the next five years shuns ed between jails gleaming,
the listening as the news from Fromm Scott West six months off to laugh,
I ads crossed the lines and Louie was guillotined ending.
Lafayette's hope of a constitutional monarchy. Another six months after this,
the reign of terror. Again,
although his former comrades in America begged versus release,
there was nothing to be done. Laugh.
I out had been sentenced to rot in the cell and Rossi woods,
at least for a while, because in just a few short years,
a great man would ride the Markey's rescue.
Perhaps the greatest man in European history,
his name was Napoleon Bonaparte and he would transform Francis. Fortunately.
[Inaudible].
During Nathalia. ANSI is in prison. The situation in France,
gradually regressed on July the 27th, 1794,
also known as nine Thermador year two Robespierre was overthrown and
subsequently guillotines in the wake of the Therma Dorian reaction,
the directory Rose to power corrupt and reaction Raisy French directory.
It would last a minute, four years before it was overthrown.
But luckily for our story today, it did two very important things.
In those four years,
the first was to promote a promising young general named Napoleon and get him to
invade Austria, to force an end to the war. The second was doing cyst.
Any peace deal included the freeing of the Marquis de Lafayette on September the
19th, 1797, Lafayette walked free of his Austrian prison. Uh,
first the market, it was like, man, this is the Polian dude is awesome.
But soon he was feeling significantly less cool about Francis new hero.
He was worried about Napoleon's ambition about his lust for power.
But if Lafayette thought Napoleon's ambition was a bit much.
Now wait until he saw what happened next on November, the ninth, 1799,
Napoleon overthrew the directory in the COO of 18 mat in place of the
directory.
He installed himself as the first concert of France dramatic as this was though
Lafayette's attention was elsewhere on December the 14th,
George Washington passed away in Virginia. Having already lost his real father.
The marquee. Now he'd lost his surrogate one. This may help explain why not.
If I had spent most of 1800 out of the picture,
it wasn't until awesome that Napoleon tried courting the hero of two worlds.
The incentive was an ambassadorship to America. When Lafayette gently,
it sounded Napoleon outside France becoming a democracy. They're applying,
he'd gone.
Wasn't encouraging Zoloft at turn down the post and began speaking out against
Napoleon in may of 1802.
It was one of the lone voices to vote against Napoleon becoming the first
console for life declaring.
I cannot vote for such a magistracy until public Liberty has been sufficiently
guaranteed,
but that guarantee never came Lafayette reside from public service that same
year. Although Thomas Jefferson offered to make a governor of newly purchased
Louisiana in 1803, Lafayette refused.
He also refused another offer from Napoleon's would be given an elevated rank in
the Legion of honor.
When the first consult finally had himself named emperor Napoleon on December
the second day, do you know for laughing?
It seems to have given up on politics entirely,
but while it stay out of the game for nearly a decade,
he wouldn't be able to resist coming back in April 18, 14,
the war of the sixth coalition ended with Napoleon advocating and being sent
into exile on the Island of Elba in the wake of the empire collapsed,
the bull and monarchy was recalled to the French throne in the portly shape of
Louis the 18th, the sights of yet another fat Louie on the throne.
Wasn't exactly music to laugh at soul in his heart.
He was still a child of the American revolution and would prefer a world without
Royals,
but when forced to choose between another Borbon King and Napoleon's continued
rain, the marquee knew who he preferred on March. The first 18,
15 Napoleon escaped the Island prison and returned to France.
Louis the 18th flat on the emperor, marched on Paris.
Kick-starting a period known as the hundred days disgusted at Napoleon's
resurrection. BAFA had to left retirement.
He took up a post in the chamber of deputies,
determined to become a lone voice against the emperor tyranny.
Instead as he winds up helping and his rule for good in the Optum off of
Waterloo that June Napoleon's brother came to the chamber to rally support for
the emperor. Instead, he was forced to listen.
As Lafayette made a barnstorming speech,
laying the deaths of millions and Napoleon's feet.
It said many of the younger deputies hadn't realized until that moment that
laugh. I, by now pushing 60 was still alive. Regardless.
The speech whacked and its aftermath off Lafayette led the charge for Napoleon's
second application on June, the 20 seconds,
the emperor obliged before Napoleon went into a second acts.
All the Maki went to the Tillary palace to thank him that Napoleon Massey,
not with anger or outrage, but with a wry smile, you got rid of me.
We like to think that smile said, but now the ball Barnes back, the Kings,
you fought so hard to read Francis off 25 years ago.
What are you going to do now? But off I would seem to have an onset,
although no one in 1815 could have realized it.
The marquee was destined to extinguish the bulb online once and for all.
[Inaudible].
Well, the next 10 years were a decade of disappointment for laugh.
I asked initially willing to give Louis the 18th of Chauncey soon became
convinced that the King needed to go starting around 18, 19.
Lafayette's began clandestinely funding,
liberal plots to overthrow the monarchy where they went nowhere by 1824,
the marquee was frustrated and all too aware that the ball bonds were catching
onto his schemes. You needed a break, a place to lie low and recalibrates,
a place where he didn't carry all the baggage that he did in France.
Luckily that place was only a boat ride away that year.
President James Monterey wrote to laugh.
I add asking if it attends celebrations of America's 50th anniversary by now,
Lafayette was the last surviving major general of the revolutionary war.
One of the last links Americans had houses to the nation's birth laugh.
I had accepted on July the 13th,
1824 laugh ads left France to begin what would become a 13 month victory tour
of all 24 us States, wherever he went,
he was fated across 9,600 kilometers. He was cheered, welcomed and honored.
It was a colossal outpouring of love towns where we named after him.
If you live in one of the dozens of places in the U S names, laugh,
I ask John's is all it was named during this journey. By the ends of the Maki.
You had seen Jefferson for the last time and visited Washington's grave had even
Simon Boulevard's nephew who was studying in the United States.
When Lafayette heard the great South American revolutionary had been inspired by
his exploits. You decide to drink to him.
And that's how boulevards Lafayette wound up becoming pen pals.
In the last years of their lives.
By the time Lafayette's left America on September the sixth, 1835,
he was pretty much all loved out.
And that was probably for the best because France was by now a pretty
unlovable place. Back in 1824, blue,
the 18th had died and the throne had passed to his brother, Charles the 10th.
But while Louis had been a Royal pain,
Charles was a throbbing Dick convinced of his divine, right to rule.
He tore up the last shreds of French liberalism,
replacing it with a hardcore Catholic hardcore conservative,
absolute monarchy. It was almost like the revolution had never happens.
Charles was trying to turn back the clock.
The 1789 Lafayette's last great act would be ensuring that he didn't succeed
on July the 26th,
1830 Charles pushed something called the four ordinances effectively,
a Royal coup they suspended freedom of the press stopped almost everyone in the
nation from voting and removed the last checks of the case.
Charles thought it would be fait accompli.
Instead it became a revolution for Brazilians.
The four ordinances were the last straw. They Rose up spontaneous driving.
Charles is forces into retreat in just three days known as the three glory.
But while the marquee and his liberal friends were happy to see Charles go,
they were less happy at the thought of all these angry Parisians suddenly
wheeling out the guillotine.
So they decided to get out ahead of the revolution while they still could.
Conscripting Charles, his cousin, Louis, Felipe. They had him ride into Paris,
draped in a trickle or a right through the revolutionary crowds,
all the way to the hotel develop their awaiting. Lafayette took the future King,
the balcony just as he had done with poor Louis, the 16th all those decades ago.
And he's waving the trickle or the two men embraced at the sight of the hero of
two worlds, bestowing his blessing on the new King.
The crowd went nuts with that one kiss. Lafayette ended the July revolution.
A few days later,
Louis Phillipe was made head of a liberal business friendly monarchy with proper
checks and balances. It was the moment the Marquis had dreamed of since 1789,
a liberal system for France in which the King was mostly a figurehead and
individual freedoms were secured. But you know what they say,
be careful what you wish for over the next four years.
Lafayette grew increasingly disillusioned with the July monarchy and it's slow
bumbling toward authoritarianism. By the end of his life.
He was one of the Louie Felipe's harshest critics are constant thorn in the King
side. Luckily for the new King,
I figured wouldn't be around much longer on may the 20th, 1834, eight 76.
The Marquis de Lafayette died in Paris.
Although many mourns in Lummi Felipe refuse to allow eulogies at his funeral.
Even having him buried under armed guard.
It was a bitter end to an extraordinary life in a seven decades on this earth.
Now, if I asked it repeatedly,
it found himself at the center of events that changed world history,
the revolutionary, the French revolution, the downfall of Napoleon.
These are all hugely significant events that would have played out very
differently without the Marquis.
And then they're all the documents that he left behind.
The one in the French constitution still incorporates the declaration on the
rights of man over 200 years after Lafayette wrote it,
but it's not just what he did or who he met. The makes the Maki impressive.
It's what he stood for all his life.
Lafayette was a tireless champion for individual Liberty and freedom from
tyranny. These were causes that took him to the battlefields of America,
into the heart of Francis revolution. Even into an Austrian prison time.
After time, people asked him to sell out the Polian Louie, the eighteens,
Louis Felipe, and each time the marquee never wavered in his beliefs.
It's often said that for evil to succeed,
all it takes is for good men to do nothing. The life of the market or laugh.
I ask, takes that saying to its opposite extreme.
It shows what can succeed when a good man decides to do something to stand up
to act, to be counted.
When a man like Lafayette decides to do that well, then he can change the world.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe brand new video several times a week, and as always,
thank you for watching.
[Inaudible].